[Music]
hello everyone this is gm josh fidel
back at you
and today i'm going to be showing a
couple of examples from carlson games
from the latest tournament
as you guys know it's gm choice and as
you guys probably know by now i like to
show games that go on in like up latest
tournaments and stuff like that as part
of my lectures
just because i have a lot of lectures
that i've prepared over the years
but i always like to have kind of fresh
looks and fresh ideas and fresh material
so
today i wanted to cover
some carlson games and specifically
not just because he won the tournament
but i want to cover a specific skill of
his so he's known for being quite good
in the endgames
uh he's known for being
really great positional player he's
pretty universal but one of the skills i
think he has that's really really strong
is that he knows how to play
material imbalances very well
and what i mean by that is positions
where it's not just even material he's
very good at evaluating imbalances
knowing who's better and why and then
playing the position the way it needs to
so
um
and by the way i am reading youtube chat
as far as the the uh this thing goes i
actually like this thing
i was wearing it because it was raining
like crazy so
thanks for reminding me i could just
wear it all lecture and pretend to be
cool but i don't really think that's uh
up my alley so
anyways i am reading youtube chat so if
you have some suggestions when i'm
asking the audience feel free
so let's start with this position
the key here is not just to figure out a
move is one thing but in order to figure
out a move you have to be able to
evaluate it
so this was his game magnus was white
against mahmud yarf
who is a very aggressive player
and true to his style he sacked an
exchange early and now has this kind of
mass of queenside pawns a weak d-pawn
all of this for the exchange sack
so i'd say that a lot of people
are good at playing with the initiative
when they sack the exchange and all of
this
but i think
what magnus shows here very very well is
how to defuse an initiative how to make
it so that the exchange stack is less
effective
and that's a very very difficult thing
to teach and to learn
so i thought that this game would be
great for that so the first question is
what's going on here and what do you
guys think white should play once again
i am viewing the youtube chat so feel
free to make suggestions
rook a8 is a perfectly decent suggestion
brian any particular reason why you like
that move
yeah james and i would say that a lot of
uh like it's really hard to understand
these games without really delving deep
into them uh and i think that to under
know that you don't understand it very
well is actually a really good step it's
easy to kind of click through and think
yeah this makes sense
so trading rooks is definitely a big
part of it
but it's also largely to make sure black
stays tied up so let me give you an
example
if you play a move like rook
fd1 black has a few different
possibilities b4 is an interesting move
but let's just say i play bishop g4
now all of a sudden you realize this d4
pawn is very weak you're tied up and you
don't really have active moves if you
start playing really passive moves
and black gets in b4 maybe b3 maybe
tries to put a knight on d3
that's where
life becomes complicated that's where
the exchange sack becomes good because
to be honest to use the extra rook for a
piece you have to think what is the
advantage of a rook for a piece and one
of them is that they can take files and
they can
you know infiltrate on ranks and things
like that but if you have kind of a
closed off position where the only open
file doesn't do much
the extra exchange is not that
meaningful
so part of the key
to
playing a position like this
is that you want to make it a position
where rooks are better than bishops or
better than knights and part of that is
obviously if the game can open up it's
very nice and that's a really good way
and the other way is exchanging rooks is
a really nice concept
i would say there are exceptions to this
but in general when you have two rooks
against one and you're up in exchange
like you are here trading off your
opponent's last rook is a very very good
technique uh very well known so carlson
does play rook 8.
so first of all
if a move like bishop g4
white has something very very simple and
strong to counter this
um any ideas
because this is the move that was
worrying us before trying to challenge
the d-pawn
so what would you guys do now
rook fv1 rook fa1 makes sense but the
problem is that you are allowing me to
for example take your knight and then
take on d4 and i feel like this is
allowing a lot like you've allowed me to
capture a pawn your bishop on f3 is a
little bit vulnerable you probably have
to go back to d1 or something i don't
know if this is exactly what you want
all right king d8 is not legal in this
position so i assume you're talking
about something else
so again think about simple and direct
you don't have to do anything too fancy
here
well it's not so easy to capture on d5
because knight takes d4 hits your queen
right so you have to at least spend
another move again i'm not saying that
position is terrible for you but i
definitely think it's not as good so
rook takes f8 i definitely like so
you're hitting h7 so the king can't
really take you have to take with the
bishop
and now what move does white have that's
quite strong
so rook takes f5 bishop takes f8 but
what's your follow-up
because again i'm i'm threatening just
to take on d4 and if i'm able to take on
d4 and then move my d-pawn i mean once
the pawns get rolling i definitely like
black's position quite a bit
but knight g5 is a very strong move so
i'm threatening mate you'd have to
defend it with something like g6 and now
the d5 pawn simply hangs
and then f7 is gonna go and that's a bit
too much that's a lot of pawns and a
very unsafe king that's going to play
black
so bishop g4 doesn't work out at all the
next one is another very direct question
what would happen after a knight takes
d4
because this is the question right like
if you're not going to play rook d1
defending your palm what happens if
black takes it
once again i think looking at
straightforward
uh ideas is correct so knight takes
knight is the obvious start but after
queen takes d4 what now
so rook d1 i assume you mean instead of
rook d8 that's correct
and now the whole idea is that
the pawn on d5 is going to to drop so
black can take on e5 but after rook
takes d5 for example queenie one check
you can play bishop f1
and here believe it or not black's just
in huge trouble
so it looks like black kind of won a
pawn out of that
but what's the the main problem and this
is the key with evaluation this is the
key with really knowing how the position
works what happened
hey mini
so what happened in
like that is not good for black what
happened to the whole position not just
a move but like the whole position
what's the problem for black now
while bishop h3 is possible but i can
also i can take this rook bishop takes
probably and then rook d1 for example
and i don't think i'm having too many
problems i can also trade i can also try
to force a queen trade or something with
queen e2
i don't think black really wants to
trade queens in this position if you
trade
now your b-pawn and c-pawn are both
goners
so you have black rank issue back rank
issues
um
you also have
so in this position you have back rank
issues the rooks are very active and the
positions opened up
and when the position opens up like this
the rooks are just a lot better than the
bishops
because they have a lot of files a lot
of things to work with and this is just
not really that great for black
so
carlson calculated knight takes d4
accurately but it wasn't just
calculation he realized that
the capture on d4
changes the position in his favor
because it opens things up
so that's kind of the key here you have
to not just calculate you have to
evaluate
so in this position um
i think that probably the best for black
would simply be to give up the trade of
rooks there's not much you can do about
it with a move like bishop b6
and possibly what chakri i was afraid of
here was this move knight g5
but after g6 i don't think it's so easy
because now
uh
the d-pawn is attacked
and
taking on e6 is not the end of the world
i don't know if this was actually what
he was afraid of maybe he was just
worried that he didn't want to trade
rook so easily but
probably white should play queen d2
and follow it up with rook a1 and i
definitely think white's better but it's
not easy black still has plenty of
counter play in a position like this
they'll play b4 trying to play b3 maybe
h6 to guard against knight g5 i
definitely don't think this position is
so simple
uh in the game he played h6 which i
don't think is a terrible move by itself
but it's definitely a slow move
so carlson played a very very normal
move here rook fa1
but there's also a very very interesting
possibility he had here which i think
may have been possibly stronger although
i can definitely understand why he
didn't go for it but
i'm curious what you guys think
b3 is a pretty normal move but it also
doesn't do like it doesn't do anything
like that outrageous for for for white
like after b3 you're not really
threatening much maybe i can try an ap4
to try to put a knight on d3 someday
i'm not exactly sure it's definitely an
okay move probably but
it's definitely not as aggressive as you
could be
queen d2 again is is kind of a solid
move but you're also not like you're
it's a little bit more passive like
you're not really threatening much i can
probably just play b4 on you
uh yes it is white smooth net h4 is
interesting but again you're allowing
knight takes d4 i don't really like that
rock fa1 is what he played in the game
which is a perfectly good move
bishop takes h4 is possible as well yeah
this is a completely different direction
this is a very very aggressive try
you're basically changing how you played
the position
and i'm actually very curious whether
carlson considered this or decided that
it wasn't that great
but there is an interesting possibility
for white here apart from rook f81 rook
fa1 was played in the game
h4 is a normal thematic move but this
moves even more aggressive
ah james found it rook takes c8 and then
queen f5
and i must say i don't know
i have doubts that i would try something
like this in the game just because i
think the exchange op position is
relatively nice
but this is actually quite annoying
because let's say black plays rook f8
trying to guard f7 i still play e6
and it's just a really irritating
position uh takes on f7 queen takes d5
are all in the air
if the bishop gets out it's going to be
just very ugly
and i don't really know how black
defends this so easily
i think queen takes d5 knight e5 like
all these moves are just coming at black
and uh
it definitely
it definitely has some problems so it
was at least an interesting possibility
the movie played in the game i feel is
more what most people would play i'd
imagine it's the most likely move for me
to play as well so knight takes d4 still
is not good for similar reasons
uh black could have tried b4 here but i
would guess that in this position he was
worried about this sack because now it's
even stronger i think potentially
because if rook d8 you play e6
and then the whole idea is that you're
ready to just to just hit on f7 like if
you try rook f8 now and i play e6 the
problem is my rook's also active
so it's an even worse version i think
and if rook d8 you have e6 and this just
gets really really tough
so bishop f6
takes and now you can't even take back
if king takes f795 check and you're
gonna lose some material
so you have to play king f8
and here probably just rookie one and
the idea now is that you're ready to
play queen e6 and try to come in
uh queen g6 queen h7 are also moves that
somehow you have to look out for
and you still don't have that much you
can do here
so again i think that this is probably
why shock didn't play b4 so he was aware
of the rook takes c8 idea
so instead he plays bishop e6
so once again
i think that carlson chooses a very very
nice move here uh that's quite precise
uh so i'm curious what you guys think of
the position so not just like if you
guys know the movie played in the game
obviously it's it's easier but apart
from just what the move is like why is
this move so precise
i assume triple stack is tripling on the
file but i think tripling on the file
will prove difficult here
it does james but i guess my main
question is why would you not take on f8
so the move played in the game was queen
d1 spoiler alert but again i think a lot
of you have seen the game so i i don't
i'm not so concerned with finding the
move but why is it better than taking on
f8
that's my main question like why is
taking on f8
a less precise move
because we talked about how when you're
playing against the pieces and you have
the rooks like it's nice to trade a pair
rooks so getting the rooks off the board
makes a lot of sense
but i actually think that carlson's move
is significantly more precise but the
reason why is a bit more subtle
why is queen d1 so much more precise
than taking nf8
let me show you an example and then you
guys can maybe tell me why if rook takes
f8 bishop takes f8 let's say queen d1
now
black can actually play the move g5 and
g4 is kind of in the air and then this
d4 pawn will be very weak and i actually
don't think white has a very obvious
answer to this move
because even moves like h3 can run into
g4 bishop takes and i understand black's
king's a bit open but if you lose your
central pawns it could become very very
unclear
so yes you do have more on the a file
what else do you have
what else is important
rook 1 to a6 sometimes can be a good
idea
but it's not just about that
let me ask you in a different way
let's say i play queen d1 here which is
what he played in the game so a shock
played b4
but let's say you play g5 now
white has a really really sweet response
to this move in this position because it
looks really annoying right i'm
threatening g4 it's the same deal of
rook cafe bishop f8u transposed what
option does carlson have now which is so
much better
you can play rook a6 but very
specifically you can play this rook to
a6
and the problem is the queen now has to
move off of attacking this pawn the
queen can no longer attack d4
so you play queen b7
and now white could try h4 first i don't
really know that it helps but even just
a move like knight e1
all of a sudden
black's position is really horrible i'm
about to just maneuver my knight to e3
this pawn is going to be weak your king
side now is terrible maybe queen h5
comes i still control the a file
and all of a sudden this g5 move becomes
completely useless and in fact it hurts
black's position
so the main reason
why carlson's way was so much more
precise and in positions like this
really precision matters because one
imprecise move in the the side that's
down the exchange is all of a sudden
gets tons of play is that he maintains
the option of rook a6
of course black can initiate the trade
himself but now the problem is he's just
down a whole temple white gets a whole
tempo to do something
not to mention that this pinned bishop
doesn't really make a positive
impression so i don't think that this is
ever something he's going to worry about
maybe now you could try to just bring
the queen oops not to a7 guys
maybe now you can just bring the queen
and try to do stuff on the a file for
example
so because you have the option of
bringing the rook back to a6 even though
you're not trading you're taking the
queen off of a crucial pawn
so it's nice to have the general
concepts that you want to trade rooks
but you also have to know
when to break them and in this case
carlson wants to maintain the option of
chasing the queen away from d4
so queen d1 is a very precise move
shock meanwhile doesn't want to just
wait around to get
to have carlson's pieces come in at him
so he plays the move b4
and once again
i believe carlson shows very very good
understanding of the position
oh
so queen a4 is definitely possible so
you're threatening i didn't analyze this
move but let's check it out so you're
threatening rook a6 that looks pretty
bad
so
probably
this definitely looks like a very
dangerous move but perhaps i can play
knight takes d4 here you you have let go
of your pawn
so i don't know maybe you can try to get
something on the back rank i was
considering so maybe
i don't know if you want to take the
knight first say let's say you do
and then take and maybe queen eight
trying to play rook eight the problem is
if i ever play queen c5 i guard my
bishop so but you're probably not
getting all that much with the k8s
so i'm guessing that's why queen a4 is
maybe not the best
uh rook one to a6 is definitely possible
but after the move let's say queen b7 i
don't know your follow up so i'm
threatening the rooks right so how do
you follow up now
because okay i mean in my mind you have
to either play queen a1 or take first
let's say you take just for argument's
sake and then play queen a1 the problem
you have now is that your queen and rook
are actually kind of tied to each other
so when i play a move like b3 you
actually have to watch out for moves
like c3 and b2 and all of a sudden your
pieces become horribly discoordinated
so i don't really know how this is going
to work you could try queen a4 but even
here c3 looks like a very strong move i
don't know how you stop these pawns
maybe you can because there's knight d2
i did i did miss that so maybe something
like
queen takes takes rook takes
pawn takes knight d2
and you save it huh
sometimes even these positions i'm less
sure of because i can play like bishop
b4
bishop f5 but i don't know if this is
gonna quite work out maybe
sometimes these the doubled pawns are
actually really nasty because you have
two pawns to get rid of now
so i'm actually not sure man i don't see
a clear wind here for white if you take
this pawn and i take your knight how do
you stop this b-pawn
it looks kind of nasty to me
i suppose you can play bishop takes b3
and then guard with the bishop somehow
so like if bishop
e4 you check and play bishop a2 maybe
bishop here
bishop a2
yeah i guess i guess here you're
probably still doing well huh
just because the bishops are very
unwieldy
so i don't know maybe maybe b3 bishop
queen a4 is possible but i also don't
have to go crazy and sacrifice my knight
like i can play a move like knight b4 to
d3
uh and again maybe you have something
here but to me this doesn't look so easy
or clear
um
yeah c3 was a bit rambunctious on my
part i just wanted to show the
spectacular pawns crashing through
yeah but what carlson did was a bit more
precise in my opinion
so again you have to think about what
does black want to achieve here what is
the what is black's major break that's
going to be really really annoying to
deal with
like what is black's idea
um so when you're facing
like here so sometimes when you're
playing with the initiative your job's
different than playing against it when
you're playing against it and i wouldn't
say it's the initiative so much as
pressure positional pressure
uh from the black pawns
a lot of it is about knowing
like how to prevent your opponent from
doing what they want to do most
and a lot of the times if you prevent
their key idea
um
then
then like they just don't have enough
they can do
no manny i didn't see it what did he
what did he have to say
they definitely are keen those central
pawns are really strong and again it's
one of the things
i think that uh carlson is actually
really underestimated in how he handles
a position like this because as you guys
see it's annoying right and i think that
if you take most grand masters even
playing whiting and chakriar in a
position like this they'd probably lose
they'd probably or at the very least
they'd be under lots of pressure would
be really difficult and magnus made
winning this game seem so easy
black's idea is to queen upon that's
part of it but specifically like what
move is black going to play which is
going to really strengthen their
position here very good keen they're
going to play b3
black playing b3 is super annoying
because not only does it lock the pawn
and give c3 ideas it also allows this
knight to get in the game and the knight
landing on d3 is also quite nasty
ah that's funny manny
but yeah magnus's play this game was
very very good
uh so he played b3
uh which is just a really really nice
move
because now you don't get to play b3
this knight on c6 looks a lot worse
and because you still have the two rooks
it's really hard to ever play knight a5
or a move like this
but there is a big drawback to this
which is you allow the move c3 and as
you guys know allowing a protected
passer in your territory is really
dangerous whether it's the middle game
or the end game
but once again magnus showed that he had
a clear idea of what he was doing here
he played b3 knowing that c3 would
happen the question is how does he then
solidify his position
yeah manny i know what you mean like
sometimes allowing the connect the
protected passer feels wrong but i would
say that allowing b3 is actually worse
like at least putting the pawn on b3
it's not just about the pawn structure
it's about the pieces
and this knight on c6 is now clearly
worse now that the pawn is on b3
blocking the b-pawn
and i think that's the key sometimes
it's not just about the pawn structure
it's about the pieces
d3 is definitely an interesting looking
move um
let me actually see queen d3 i didn't
look at
um
it doesn't look bad to me
yeah i don't have a great response to
this move
maybe black just plays g6 and tries to
put the bishop here and then the queen
move maybe it doesn't look quite as good
that's one possibility
so i think that the move he played in
the game i think i saw this mentioned
was rook back to a6
and the key is that now once again the
queen has to let go of this pawn he
plays queen c7
and now he plays 91 and this is the key
once again he chooses not to trade rooks
which as we know is not really in the
spirit of the position at first
but the key idea is that now he controls
the a file so this knight can't go
anywhere and once the knight gets to c2
black's going to be completely paralyzed
so for example let's say black plays
rook d8 which is a logical looking move
he plays knight c2 let's say g6 you can
play h4
h5 preventing h5 and then knight e3
and black's basically just lost this
d-pawn's horribly weak he has no active
moves at all
and he's completely under control
think about how different this is than
the position where bla white allows b3
and there's a huge pawn chain
so it's really quite something this
maneuvering which basically made all of
white's pieces good and now black has
almost no compensation at all
he could have tried manny but he's still
down a tempo right
like after b3 the problem is he doesn't
have time for this because after takes
takes bishop f8 he can take on c4 and
then if recaptures c
d5 and you're getting forked right so
this is no good so when does he have
time to do that right
if he does it early then he's gonna give
give white a chance to maybe play queen
a1 and get the queen out
so where does he have time to play rook
takes a a that's the issue
so this 91 move is really good so shock
realizes that
okay my position is really bad
and
i would say that gm's in particular
now shock is a very aggressive player so
that's part of it but i'd say gm's in
particular when they're positioned they
view their position as if i just play
slow moves i'm going to lose 100 that's
when they start to lash out
i would say though that elite players in
general
are very good at not lashing out too
early and i'd say most amateur players
try to lash out too early they're like
well i don't like my position let's go
crazy
and
sometimes it works but for the most part
if you lash out too early you just lose
quicker
and that's kind of what happened here
but i would say that here i understand
because if black plays slow moves he's
just gonna lose a very painful death
which might not take that long anyway
so he tried f6 just trying to mix up the
game trying to open up his rook and it
was a move i understood
but again this is where
magnus really
shows his understanding because he
responds very well and very directly to
this move
and i'd say again this is something you
can learn from any top player which is
that
they can have a plan of putting the
knight on c2 which is his whole plan
this whole time but they can change
their plan on a dime if their opponent
plays differently
i think a lot of people they get a plan
and they just follow it through almost
no matter what happens and sometimes
that's not a very good strategy so after
f6 what's the way that white can kind of
punish this
so f4 is kind of
it's playable but it also opens you up a
lot like this would shock would love to
see this move because pawn takes if pawn
takes i have bishop c5 check type things
and if you take this way
maybe even knight takes d4 actually in
this i didn't see that
maybe you have rook takes e6 i don't
know exactly but even if you don't let's
say there's no knight takes d4 and you
play here this is exactly what shock
wants he's maybe getting counterplay his
bishop's in the game
so he instead plays the move knight d3
and the whole idea now is that knight f4
is a monster threat so shock takes but
after knight takes this rook
is now
skewering the knight to the bishop and
after takes takes he just has too many
pieces hanging
so he tried c2 but after queenie one he
just resigns because he's basically just
all his guys are loose and the c pawn is
not strong enough
for example if he tries bishop g5 maybe
the best bet
then you have to deal with simply pawn
takes knight
queens and
he's only he's down two pawns in an
opposite bishop game but this is
basically hopeless because what happens
is the bishop kind of parked itself on
g6 and then you don't move ever again
um and then you'd basically just
it's just very bad so he didn't want to
see any part of this
so he resigned
after queenie one
but a really really nice game and again
it shows his understanding of how to
play
up an exchange he basically limited
black's counterplay took over the a file
used the file the fact that rooks are
better with a file
uh but then had a very clear idea of how
to improve he improved his 9 f3 by
keeping the option of rook a6 open and
then once he maneuvered his knight black
was basically in big trouble i also want
you guys to make note of the move b3 he
played which really made it so that
black couldn't play b3 himself and get
pieces into the game so even though he
allowed a protected passer he saw he had
a way to blockade it and he also saw
that it stopped black's pieces from
getting in
and this is stuff that is really really
difficult to understand without taking
a closer look but when you take a closer
look i mean the game didn't look close
at all but it wasn't because shock just
played horribly or anything like that
necessarily it was just almost perfect
play up the exchange
but now this is where i want to show
like one of the things again i think
that's a real skill of his is he's good
playing
up the exchange trying to be technical
like he was this game to prevent counter
play he's also good
at this
so he reached this this position against
anish giri and some of you may know what
he played here but for those of you who
haven't seen the game uh take your time
see what uh you would play here as white
i'm also curious like what you guys
think is going on
okay
yeah this is the one drawback i love to
show modern games and go over them with
you guys but you guys have definitely
you know a lot of you especially if you
follow chess events have seen the games
before
um so you might know some of the games
and some of the moves but keep in mind
that a lot of the times i'm more focused
on why he played the moves than what
moves he played
so knight h4 is possible but again i
don't think you want your knight on h4
so i don't know how great this move is
going to be for you
so again i mean maybe maybe it does
force the queen trade or something like
that but again you don't really want a
knight on h4 right so i might be able to
take on d4 i don't know but even if i
have to do this right
and let's say
i guess i guess if i take i'm losing
this b paw the c pawn
honestly though even a position like
this let's say i played knight d5 give
you this guy come here
i feel like your your b pawn is going to
be quite weak here yeah and your knight
is still a bit out of play probably not
the best i can do though i'm sure i
could do better than queen takes queen
maybe queen b5 or queen takes d4 is is
kind of interesting
but the main issue is that because your
knights really ought to play on h4 you
need a lot of things to go your way for
this to be good for you
so
yeah
so i saw knight take knight to e5 in the
comments uh this move has a very bad
flaw it would be very nice but quite a
g2 mate is a big problem
and don't worry about it we all blunder
mate in one
once in a while it is something that
happens but yeah in the game he played
rook takes c6 and the main thing here is
that
i don't necessarily think he did this
thinking all right i'm gonna crush him i
think he did it because if he doesn't
sack on c6 what is he doing here i mean
net h4 again i i doubt is very strong
and otherwise like he could play queen
back or something but it looks kind of
lame blacks up a pawn keep in mind so
even though he has some good
compensation i feel like if he doesn't
sack the exchange
he just doesn't have anything to play
for
so he does choose to sack which i think
is correct he plays knight e5 which is a
good follow-up opening up is bishop
queen b5
and again i know some of you have
have seen the game before so if you guys
can refrain at least from saying the
move
but here's another question so he has to
decide
whether he plays something like bishop
takes pawn and try to cash in basically
try to win some of his material back
he's down in exchange in a pawn remember
or whether he should keep the tension in
some way
so that's kind of the question for you
guys would you guys try to keep tension
or would you try to cash in
and i would say that this is where again
understanding how imbalances work
really is important
because that's one of the hardest part
of imbalances to know when should i cat
when to cash in and when not to cash in
so you would keep tension fair enough
any particular reasons though like why
would you keep tension why would you
take on b7 does it just work tactically
like what what do you guys think
well i'll tell you one thing after
bishop takes b7 how does black hold on
to the exchange at all
liam makes a good point which is that
you're creating open files which
definitely can favor the side that
has the extra rook but i would argue
though that bishop takes b7 does not
really
like white will win the exchange back
because let's say bishop takes b7 rook
b8 right
i can play bishop c6 now and that's a
lot of stuff that's going to hang
a lot of stuff that's going to hang
after queen takes queen takes
takes for example
uh
i can take the rook i can take the
knight i might also just move a piece
like something like rook a1 might be
really annoying
for
example uh because yeah if you try to do
this takes check
i don't think it's gonna work out for
you because after rook a1 i have knight
c4 and these pieces actually coordinate
extremely well
so i don't think this would be so easy
this is the thing though there are times
when you do try to cash in you do try to
trade your
extra exchange in for more pieces but it
turns out that black has a very very
strong idea after bishop takes b7
keep in mind vincent that you're not
really going to stay down the exchange
like i think white wins the exchange
back
so the question is why didn't magnus go
for it he did choose to keep tension
but why did he do that
so there's understanding there's also
precise calculation
but what does black have here that's
quite good
yeah so liam that could be true but i
would say that again it's not really a
general question like
sometimes you just should take material
back because it's the best way to play
the question is what can why isn't it
good here the lines we saw before look
pretty good for white so why isn't this
good here
because you could take any strong player
and you could say well this is more a
move that karpov would play this is a
move that kasparov would play i use them
as examples because i'm i'm giving uh
i'm doing some classes with kids and i'm
using them as examples but the fact is
that both of those guys are trying to
just play good moves right and the same
with carlson so
you could say that they have tendencies
which is true but ultimately they're
trying to find the best continuation
so
i would say he didn't keep tension
because he's magnus he kept tension
because he thought it was the best
continuation the question is why did he
think that
like i definitely think that people
think about style too much like most of
these guys are trying to find good moves
finding good moves in chess is hard
enough
they definitely have leanings if the
situation's close
uh and there are certain mistakes more
some players are like for example
kasparov if his best course of action is
to retreat and try to defend he might be
less likely to play it than another
player
but that doesn't mean that he wouldn't
do it like these guys are all trying to
find good moves
knight c5 i think i can take it james
but i think you you're very close
so basically the best way very good gara
i'm sure i'm butchering your name i
apologize for that but yes knight c3 you
can also take on b3 first i think
they're pretty similar because they
probably transpose but yeah knight c3 so
if queen takes c3 queen takes b7 so
probably i take here
and now most likely you trade queens at
some point
you can do it immediately or you can
check first maybe check first because
then
i can't go to h1 due to knight takes g3
it's kind of nice so king g2
and now you trade
and rook uh rook takes a8
and i think this position if any if it's
good for anyone it's good for black the
knight on d5 is going to be very good
this knight is coming out
or maybe it will hit this pun
and i think that the b pawn is also
quite weak like something like rook b8
and trying to target the b-pawn is very
strong
so
carlsen would have won all his material
back he'd be even material
uh and his king is better the king on g2
is more promising than the king on g8
that's for sure but i would say the
knight on d5 is such a strong piece that
prevents him from getting in and his
pawns are weaker than blacks the a6 and
c7 puns are not as weak as the b3 and d4
pawns
so i think that this is why he didn't go
for this not because he's carlson not
because of style but because he didn't
believe it led to advantage and if
anything i think it leads to a worse
position
so he played the tension maintaining
move queen c2 which is a really great
move
it looks slow but the idea is rook b1 is
coming
and will be really devastating he's not
really in a rush to take all the pawns
although queen takes c7 trying to take
this pawn is very tempting as well
um
so here probably like geary
gary had an improvement move i think
knight b6 is maybe the best move
and again it wasn't a move i found right
like i checked these games with computer
afterwards but it felt like a very
hard move to find because you're
allowing queen take c7 but the idea is
you can block with a knight and it helps
a lot
another idea is that after rook b1 you
have to move queen a4
and somehow your position holds together
here
like they can take on c7
but you can grab this a3 bishop and
you're able to get enough counter play
but once again these lines are very very
difficult
i know manny that's the key but the key
is to realize that after queen c2 you're
actually not losing the initiative queen
c2 you get to keep the initiative
and that's the key thing to realize here
so i think that geary played a mistake
but a very understandable one with
knight d5
so carlson plays rook b1
queen a5 and here i actually think he
maybe could have been slightly more
precise
than he was
so he played the move bishop takes d5
which looks great after he takes d5 he
kind of crashed through and got a good
position
but i think he actually could have been
even he could have done even better here
and my question is how is that possible
and actually i'll show you part of the
issue with what he did so after bishop
takes d5 i think queen takes d5 is a
better defense
because now for example if you go here i
can play f6
force your knight back and take on a2
and i don't think this is all that clear
because this pawn hangs as well and if
you lose a lot of pawns even if you have
two pieces against the rook this is not
going to be so easy
so i think that this would have been a
better defense and if queen takes pawn
i think that he can play
f6 now
still
i want to say or no there's rook takes
me so hold on there's some other defense
here
um
oh yeah you have to play something like
b5 or just just like prevent rook takes
b7 something like this
and allow queen takes f7 check and
somehow this position you can kind of
survive but this is
very very difficult to do
but i definitely think that this was his
best shot because the other lines are
not
like
taking with the pawn is what he did then
that just is a disaster so queen takes
d5 is kind of the key
uh so the key is like how do you prevent
this from the white perspective and it's
actually really cool how you do it
so rook p3 threatening knight c4 the
problem is rook b3 allows queenie one
check i don't think you want to allow
queenie one
e4 is kind of a move that
in this kind of structure people play e4
too easily in my opinion and the main
problem is it blocks your bishop in this
case though i think it does allow knight
c3
uh is it maybe a problem or even queen
not queen c3 you take so probably knight
c3
um and i don't know how easy it is you
do have bishop b4 though so maybe this
is
not so great
yeah i'd have to check actually e4 maybe
maybe the knight actually doesn't go
there
ah perhaps i play this knight to c3
because now i'm hitting your bishop and
your rook
there's rook b3 though
i'm refuting every move i play maybe
maybe e4
has more to it huh
yeah as i said like these positions are
very complicated right so i'm not always
positive that everything is
is so simple and during a game these
guys have to figure all this out right
so it's
it makes it even more challenging i
would say
second on f7 is very tempting but i the
problem is i think you run out of pieces
e4 though actually may have some merit
here yeah
i suppose you can play knight back to f6
i don't quite see the refutation here
bishop before you can move your queen
maybe to b5 or something
i don't know though it looks very flimsy
yeah i don't know e4 may have been quite
strong
so the key is you want to take on d5 but
you want to weaken black's king first
that's the best hint i can give you here
again i don't blame anyone for not
playing this i think that it's very
difficult to spot but
so bishop e4 is actually extremely
clever
um so one of the one of the deals here i
think is that
if you try to move your knight away
if you try to move your knight back i
think now bishop b4 is is like crushing
something like this
or no i think i can just take your pawn
or something like you just lose all your
pieces something like bishop takes pawn
and knight here and you just lose
everything i have to check though knight
f6 i don't remember uh the main thing is
if f5 and then i take the knight the
problem is if you take back this way
you can't shoot my knight away like
because my knights here basically
permanently you can't play f6 and not
being able to play f6 is a big problem
even if you take my a2 pawn you're going
to get mated somehow
um
so f5 is and if e takes then it's kind
of similar to how it would occur in a
game except even worse
uh and bishop takes h7 is like a mate
threat right
so but yeah knight f6 i'm actually kind
of curious myself because
uh there was definitely a refutation to
this move but i have to recall exactly
what it was
um
yeah unfortunately one of the things is
uh like i usually copy my notes into
leaches and somehow my notes to this
game didn't copy so i'm going based on
memory the good thing is you can see uh
what it's like to calculate these and
how difficult it is i think it is bishop
takes b7 actually because if queen c3 is
not a threat because of queen takes a4
so if something like this
you can't just defend with queen c3
because queen takes a4 and this looks
crushing
so i'm gonna guess that it's it's bishop
takes b7 i could be wrong
but it does look very very strong
in any case it's really hard to play a
move like bishop e4 when you can be more
forcing
bishop h7 knight f7 i don't know i think
you're giving away a lot of pieces
unfortunately
in your line manny i think the e4 bishop
hangs at the end is the issue
um
yeah unfortunately
but okay he took here and after he takes
d5 it's actually quite amazing how fast
his position falls apart
he plays rook takes b7
and here again it's a really difficult
position for black
there are better defenses than what he
did but it's also very tough so he plays
this move
and now how do you continue the attack
he does it in quite ruthless fashion
but if anything you can see the main
issue that gary had this game was that
because he didn't find the one really
difficult move his pieces basically
couldn't coordinate very well
and kind of like against shock magnus
found a way to coordinate his pieces
very well so all his pieces work
together nicely and blacks do not and
that's kind of the main difference here
so i don't know bishop takes knight
takes like again you don't really want
to be trading pieces so he wants to be
making threats not training pieces queen
f5 is what he does very good
so now quite x7 is a huge threat
so he plays rook of fate
but now the question is what has he
taken with what that's kind of the key
so rook takes probably is more forcing
the issue with it
maybe is that
let me see and again this might win like
i'm not saying this move doesn't win um
the funny thing is i don't know that
it's more forcing because the problem is
like i guess you're threatening rook
takes rook and queen e6 so let's say i
prevent it with a move like
maybe queen
maybe queen b6
because now you you don't really
you have to worry about queen bee one
check always
oh wait you can take sorry i'm not
paying attention to tactics
takes and i guess this is just two pawns
huh it's good enough
so queen b6 is a bit of an unfortunate
move
the thing is again i think a lot of
moves won so i don't think i'm trying to
find like a a drawing move i think i'm
just trying to find maybe i can survive
for a couple moves kind of thing
but
ah maybe knight c3 is an idea just
trying to hang on to d5
but then queen e6
i don't know
your move looks looks good enough to be
winning to me
knight takes f7 though is what he played
and i think that this move makes a lot
of sense because he's threatening to
take the pun in addition to stuff like
ned h6 is on the horizon
uh there's just a lot of stuff to deal
with here
so he
played queen d8 which is actually kind
of clever to defend the pawn after queen
check and here
how does white win i think it's actually
quite simple
very good eduardo
queen takes d5 and the problem now is
that knight h6
is simply a
winning threat
um you could try to press on with a move
like h5 but you're you're not going to
survive very long
um
so yeah knight h6 followed by the the
classic mate just to show you guys what
it looks like let's say knight c3
i'm sure most of you guys have seen
the smothermate but
here we are
so yeah
so anish played queen d8 which is
actually quite clever
and then this is again where i think
that carlson has to use his judgment so
part of the judgment as i said is when
to cash in so he knew not to cash in
with bishop takes b7 earlier but i think
here he decided to cash in and it was a
very important decision on his part
so how does he decide to cash in
net h6 before which move though
so negative six is definitely a
possibility here you can't take the
knight because of mate but after king h8
i don't know that there's anything too
clear
d take c5 is indeed a cache and that's
what he does
so the main idea is that he basically
sees that he doesn't have force mate so
he's basically trying to create a very
dangerous pass pawn while keeping this
very very strong bishop and leaving the
knight sideland on a4
so anish plays queen f6 which was his
main idea
and now how does he complete the cash in
here how does he make it so that
he
gets enough material to ensure a win
so queen d5 i think now knight c3 is an
issue and you don't have mate and you
have a lot of stuff attacked so the
queen's attack the knights attacked
it's a lot of stuff i can't take on f7
you're correct in that at least because
of rook takes f7 and this a8 rook hangs
but i think knight c3 is quite an
annoying move
he plays much simpler than that guys
yeah queen d5 knight c3 i think is
annoying so he played a much simpler way
yeah knight c3 is pretty annoying
and that's the key right like it's it's
one thing to outplay your opponent so
badly but one of the things that makes
these top guys the top guys is that they
don't spoil it at the end they find the
the way to get to the end obviously not
always but
yeah he simply takes the queen
he gives a check and he plays c6
it looks kind of sad to he had this
great attacking initiative game and now
he's just trained to an end game but
sometimes especially against good
defense and these guys defend amazingly
well
you have to win in kind of a prosaic way
where you're basically like well like
all right i guess i just traded a
winning end game
and the reason this is so winning is
because the c pawn is very strong the
knight's out of play and the king is
still not very good there
so anish plays here
c7 and now he can't really move either
rook the bishop controls this key square
so he's kind of just dead
he tries knight c3
but here bishop b2 is kind of a clever
move
so if the knight takes the pawn he plays
king f1
and you're threatening mate and the
knight so this isn't going to end well
so he plays d4
but now knight f7 chuck and knight d6 so
he's gonna win back in exchange
but keep in mind he doesn't have to take
it right away
he plays king g7 and here he simply
plays king f1 he says you're not even
getting my pawn
and this is the other key he doesn't
really feel like he has to rush here he
can just try to take the exchange at any
time
knight b5 he finally takes the exchange
and then a4 to make sure to undermine
this pawn
takes takes
and after 96 bishop e3 black resigns
because even though white traded to an
end game there's no mate he's up two
pawns and rook b6 is coming so there's
no rook c4 because rook b6
hits and you're hitting both things
so this is not going to go very well
so he basically just resigns
and again i i think that
the
the real key to all of this is that
you have to know when to cash in and
when you get a position like in the end
game that dominating even though you're
down in exchange when you have a pawn on
c7 the knight coming in it was clear to
him that this would be winning so this
is good enough you can't always give
checkmate
so i feel like
both of these games really show like one
of the things that made him win this
tournament and also just what makes him
strong in that
if he's if he has the position he's up
material defending against the
initiative he knows how to restrict play
and then
slowly
fix his pieces and improve when he's
playing with the initiative he knows
when to keep the tension and then knows
when to relieve the tension or when to
try to when to liquidate and he knows
that largely i think by feel but also
he does a lot of calculating
a lot of looking ahead
and
as you can see it's a very very useful
skill to develop and i think by studying
his games you can really get there
so
manny that's a really good way to put it
that basically if you're not finding a
knockout
then
it often means that there is no knockout
and maybe you have to try to trade to a
winning game or something
so very very nice game and again a great
tournament by him just really dominating
performance
but i hope you learned a lot from these
games both from the up and exchange side
and the down exchange side and that
maybe you'll have a bit more confidence
playing material imbalances which is one
of the most difficult things to do
thank you davina
in any case i hope you guys enjoyed the
enjoyed the video
and uh i'll be here for more on the next
one i believe is
on thursday evening i'll be doing a
preparation a video on tournament
preparation so stick around for that and
i will see you guys later have a good
one
[Music]
you